As you can see, sound is a really important part of any project, especially
games.
>> Take for example Half Life 2. Someone out there actually made an entire mod
pack to replace the sounds of the original game. So, instead of hearing
footsteps you heard duck quacks, instead of hearing the missile hitting the
alien, you actually heard a crowd laughing. The result was pretty offsetting.
You didn't really feel like you were connected in the environment. The drama
was gone, the suspense was gone, it really wasn't the same game.
>> Now it's also worth pointing out, that sound design is often one of the more
expensive parts of production. It's long, tedious work, and often tied very
closely to the design of the game. Take for example Quake one, when your quad
damage was running out, the designer decided that you'd get a three second
pulse warning you that it was about to run out. Now if you actually look at the
code, they coded in the bright flashes that you see, once every second.
However, the sound itself was actually a three second clip with the pulses. If
the artist of designers came back and actually decided they wanted a different
length, shorter or longer, the sound would have to be started from scratch.
This is why sound design is usally really expensive for video games, and left
to the end. Most of these changes happen very iteratively, so you have to end
up scrapping a lot of the work you've been doing.